We're as salespeople, we get on these calls and we're thinking in our heads, you know,
as soon as we get off the call, we think that the customer gets off the call and they're just
thinking about us. Oh, should I join? Should I join this guy's lead generation program where
he's going to get me these leads? And you think that they're sitting there writing lists and
calling people and guys. And the reality is, is the second that you get off that call,
they're not thinking about you. They're not thinking about you. And the highest,
the most highest chance you have of closing that deal is on the call. And this is one of
the lines I love that you use, Kyle. And your closing is you say to people, you know, as much
as you're going to know, you're ever going to know about me, about this deal, this, you know,
the most that you're going to know right now. That's, and that's the reality. They're not
going to get off the call and go do more research. Right. And I know someone's going to go, well,
yeah, maybe one, maybe, maybe Bob and Bob's a serial killer. Okay. That, that it's not the
reality. People do not go and do more research. The reality is they have an answer. And I'll say
that to people all the time. I'll say, look, here's, what's going to happen, Bob, you know,
what the answer is. And I would rather you, I'm a big boy. I could sleep at night. I've got other
people I'm talking to. This is no sweat, man. If this doesn't make sense, then that's fine. But I
just don't want to be, you know, drug on it. I don't do, I don't, I don't do, I want to think
about it. So I'm sorry if that rubs you wrong. That's just how I am. Here's what's going to
happen. Bob, you're going to get off this call. And in five seconds, you are going to admit to
yourself the answer that you already know. And it's either yes or no. So Bob, which one is it? Do
you want to do this deal or you want me to go to freaking Jack down the street? Boom. Okay. That's